our body is bombarded by
several pathogens every day and these
pathogens
could be like viruses bacteria
fungi or even helminths most of the
cases
our body knows how to deal with these
pathogens and
these pathogens get resolved easily by
the immune system of our body
which is the defense system which
protects us
against all these external pathogens
however
our immune system might get confused
in case of some kind of novel pathogens
let's imagine there is a noble virus
in this case our immune system would be
super confused
that where does this virus come from
because it is simply
not stored in their records
so first of all our immune system would
try to gather intel about the virus but
this virus
is nasty by the time our immune system
gathers
in info about this virus
these pathogens would increase and
multiply
inside our body and then they would
mount a very strong
response in the body
so that is why our body becomes
weak and our immune system could not
resist these
viruses now job of a vaccine
is to raise an alarm to the immune
system
and make the immune system more
knowledgeable about the upcoming
pathogen attack
so the vaccination tells the immune
system about the presence or the nature
of the
virus or bacteria or even the nature of
the antigen
that they possess such that immune
system would have a complete
profile of what is coming and they would
prepare themselves ahead of time
it's like a mock drill that happens in
army so let's talk about vaccines
and their types so vaccines could be of
different type
and in this particular video we are
going to talk about
live attenuated vaccine let's talk about
what is a life attenuated vaccine how
they
work what are what are the advantages
and disadvantages
etc so live attenuated vaccines
are nothing but entire microorganisms in
an
attenuated format or in an inactivated
format
so let's say this is an active virus by
chemical means
one can attenuate this virus so now this
virus is kind of
inactive and this virus
could be then introduced in format of an
injection or a vaccine
now this virus which is attenuated it's
like a dead body of virus
so obviously it's not able to infect the
body
but the immune system would recognize
that
and alarm all the other components of
the immune system about
about this possible infection that might
happen in the future
so immune system would be ready in prior
for any future attack
now one example of these kind of live
attenuated vaccine
dates back to 18th century when
smallpox was a pandemic at the same time
one observation was life changing
the milk maids in england they developed
cow pox now cow pox was not lethal and
these milk maids do not develop small
pox this
milkmaid had small blisters in their
hand
but often these are not deadly
so cowpox virus and smallpox virus are
pretty similar
looking at this kind of logic edward
jenner took out some fluid
from these postures and injected
it into a healthy individual
next time when the healthy individual
who is injected with this partial
extract is not any more affected by
a small box virus in other words
this pers person is immune to smallpox
virus
so how did that happen as smallpox virus
is pretty much similar to the cowpox
virus
injecting some amount of fluid from the
postule
brings about an immunity against a
similar kind of virus which is the
smallpox virus and this was a
crude example of life attenuated vaccine
now there are many more examples that we
know for example
we can talk about polio vaccine or the
semi-polio vaccine
formulated by albert sabine so in that
case
active poliovirus is attenuated and that
is incorporated
orally and that kind of
eradicated polio from the world
another one is bcg vaccine
taking this example we would understand
that how these kind of live attenuation
process
can work so
bcg which is attenuated format of
mycobacterium this was generated
by growing mycobacterium strain
in a bile containing media after growing
them for a very long time they have
adapted to grow
a media which contains bile so obviously
they do not grow that much in a
body situation or in a normal
situation so that is why they cannot
survive
but once they are injected they cannot
perform any kind of infectious uh kind
of symptoms
but our immune system can be alarmed
by their presence and this is how bcg
vaccine worked
already we have taken three examples of
live attenuated vaccine
now let us talk about more so these live
attenuated vaccine
are generally unable to grow in the body
but it raises an alarm to the immune
system it
informs the immune system about an
upcoming infection
and it gives the immune system enough
time
to prepare such that if any kind of
infection happens in the future
they are fully prepared to encounter
so let us talk about the advantage and
the disorder disadvantage
of this vaccine especially the live
attenuated vaccine
first of all life attenuated vaccines
give rise to very strong
immune response so it activates the
immune system
very strongly that's the biggest
advantage of life attenuated vaccine
and due to these strong immune response
there is no need to give
booster doses but there are quite a lot
of disadvantage of
using a live attenuated vaccine there
are a lot of side effects
because many of the cases there are
chances of
reinfection these attenuated ones might
escape the attenuation and might grow
inside the body
and they can infect instead of protect
so there could be other adverse side
effects
as well so these are the major
disadvantages
for which people these days do not
prefer
live attenuated vaccines anymore
however we should always understand
that live attenuated vaccines are
inexpensive
second of all it does not require any
booster dose
think about the developing countries or
the third world countries
once you give one dose the patient might
not return
for the booster dose again so the
vaccination course might be
incomplete from that point of view if
you have a strong
immune response boosting vaccine
one dose might be enough and that's the
biggest advantage
of the life attenuated vaccine despite
of the disadvantages
still many of these live attenuated
vaccines are still used
in the third world countries so in this
video we have discussed
how live attenuated vaccine works how
live attenuated vaccine is
made and lastly the advantages and the
disadvantages of live attenuated vaccine
so i hope you enjoyed this video if you
like this video give it a quick thumbs
up
don't forget to like share and subscribe
and if you want to access my code
in an academy you can always use my code
ap 10 for 10 discount
and you can also support me in patreon
thanks for listening and do let me know
in the comment how you like my videos
thank you